rock on reste chez nous en bourgogne
france comté avec deux collégiennes
quand on vide nous parler de quelques
réseaux sociaux et notamment de snapshot
alors nous on est tout ouïe avec
marianne et je suis sûr que ceux qui
sont avec nous aussi se disent ah oui
forcément
qui mieux que les jeunes pour parler de
snapshot snapshot c'est quoi pour vous
les faits c'est un réseau social qui est
très utilisé on peut soit prendre
d'estoril pour montrer à tous les gens
qu'on fait alors le story c'est quoi
précisément en fait une historie c'est
c'est par exemple un maître défunt on va
mettre des photos ou des vidéos d'un
history et tout va pouvoir la voir mais
au bout de 24 heures elle va s'effacer
en fait d'accord jusque là moi j'ai tout
compris marilyn dessus voilà ça dure 24
heures mais attention quand même un
informaticien pour piquer des trucs un
peu plus tard donc puis méfiance
méfiance
on entend souvent parler des flammes de
staps chat c'est quoi les flammes de
snapshot et c'est un concept qui en fait
faut envoyer des snacks des vidéos des
photos à une même personne
tous les jours donc la personne doit
aussi vous envoyer des photos tous les
jours c'est comme une conversation en
famille dans la station en photos et en
vidéos et au bout de trois jours il ya
un petit smiley flammes qui s'affiche à
côté du nom de la personne avec laquelle
vous échanger et donc c'est au bout de
trois jours d'accord vous utilisez oui
ouais c'est ce qu'on voit là c'est
l'application téléphone je dis ça aux
parents aux grands parents qui
connaissent pas peut-être forcément ce
réseau l'heure parce que c'est vrai qu'à
la beaucoup ça fait partie des stars des
réseaux marines est plus tout le réseau
des jeunes générations les vos parents
aux grands-parents sont peut-être plus
sur facebook chef
ouais c'est ça snapshots et le petit
fantôme là comme ça qui se baladera fond
hockey quels sont les avantages pour
vous les faits de ce réseau
bah ça nous permet déjà de rester en
contact avec nos amis on sait ce qu'ils
font et
bah inversement ils savent un petit peu
ce qu'on fait et aussi ça nous permet
enfin c'est un petit peu une
satisfaction personnelle à dire d'avoir
une flamme de plus tous les jours tu as
vous dire entre guillemets un nouvel ami
c'est ça mais c'est vraiment briller
mais cui c'est en tout cas quelqu'un
avec qui on va nuire aux relations
ouais et du coup pas d'avoir une flamme
de plus tous les jours jusqu'à atteindre
des nombres qui sont très importants
qu'est-ce que ça t'apporte à toi et ben
appareils
j'aime bien savoir ce que les autres
font ce que du coup généralement il m d
faut y mettre des photos d'eux des
activités qu'ils font est comme ça je
suis un peu cogité marie c'est bien nous
aussi on était curieux c'était un peu
différent n'avait pas ces réseaux là
mais voilà c'est la génération et c'est
le programme peut pas lutter contre le
progrès qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
justement il ya des inconvénients quand
même un snapshot cachez vous avez
conscience selon vous c'est quoi ces
inconvénients
ja ça prend beaucoup de temps pour tout
envoyer parce que généralement on fait
avec beaucoup de personnes donc faut
appuyer appuyé sur les personnes qu'on
veut et aussi quand on reçoit
généralement il ya des vidéos et elles
sont longues donc on a peur de les
zapper entre guillemets du coup on
devient accro quoi c'est presque une
addiction un petit peu comme d'autres
bouchez vous les oreilles je parle de
cigarettes je parle d'alcool sur la
musique ce sera meilleur mais oui ça
c'est quand même assez mangé beaucoup de
temps combien de temps vous y passez
vous
bah quand on ouvre tous les fins le
temps d'ouvrir tous les to les snap de
regarder les vidéos et de nous-mêmes
envoyer les stops on prendra enfin moi
je consacre au moins 10 minutes tous les
matins pour et en plus si on veut si on
veut regarder l'historique des autres en
plus ça fait moins web oiseaux et lit
les parents là qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensent de tout ça ils comprennent pas
du tout comprennent pas pourquoi on les
fait à quoi ça sert c'est une autre
génération ils jouent à la wii voilà
c'est ça maryline vous qui avez des
enfants bientôt vous allez voir en tant
que maman je me dis mince 30 minutes par
jour
elle pourrait lire elle pour écouter la
musique elle pouvait dessiner elle
pourrait faire tellement de choses plus
intéressantes et d'aller espionner
famille mais effectivement une
différence de 4 heures de ba ne pas
savoir quelque chose qui se passe
d'important et du coup de palette au
courant au collège parce que ça a beau
être futile quand même est-ce que
franchement elle zazzo les regardez moi
est ce que vraiment vous pourriez
arrêter d'envoyer ses flammes ou ou
arrêtez d'aller faire un tour sur cet
axe chaque foyer franche n'est pas on
regarde pas non plus d'accord moi c'est
le mérite d'être clair c'est honnête
c'est super tout cas moi je vous
remercie d'avoir été aussi franche avec
nous on a compris que c'était dur dur de
se déconnecter c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire notamment des écrans et pas
forcément de la télévision est aussi
plein d'autres écrans plus ou moins
connectés attention les filles quand
même là on va passer pour des vieux cons
mais attention de ne pas devenir
dépendant 1 voilà voilà faut
impérativement décrocher de temps en
temps pour que le sar ou s'ennuie 1 1
ennuyée vous pendant les vacances
oublier nos craintes et oublier les
réseaux sociaux et puis merci d'être
venu vous allez laisser votre place à
deux copines qui vont venir vous
retrouver d'ici quelques minutes juste
avant
est-ce que vous suivez le parcours de
l'équipe de france de foot féminin oui
oui oui je connais pas trop tous les
matches fermés je regarde alors là on
est en huitièmes de finale a marre lna
ça c'est sûr ce sera lundi soir à rennes
1 figurez vous que les élèves de 4e du
collège victor hugo de besançon se sont
penchés sur l'événement sportif du
moment
cette fameuse coupe du monde de football
féminin c'est l'info vue par des copains
et des copines comme vous par des ados
regarder
surtout en touche à rien ne bougeait pas
rester avec nous pour l'instant le reste
de l'actuelle larivot 18e reportage télé
le sujet que vous avez choisi de traiter
et ben les couples féminins du cette loi
ou c'était yala basculement de son
dauphin en france est ce que vous voulez
connaître quelles questions vous voulez
vous et où quelques personnes vous
voulez rencontrer
on va aller voir etienne thomas il
s'occupe de développer le foot féminin
on va recadrer le responsable de la
section sportive des tribunes a laissé
faire ce que vous voulez savoir sur foot
féminin monsieur foot féminine a le foot
masculin s'est joué de la même manière
on m'a dit qu'on tape on a plein de
questions à poser
il est prêt à partir allez c'est parti
pour le 18 heures
[Musique]
premier rendez vous de la journée pour
ebay les lamia le stade des orchamps
c'est là que les filles de la section
foot du lycée pergaud s'entraîne trois
fois par semaine la ruse et cherche du
regard
depuis bientôt vingt ans stéphane
barbeau forme des adolescentes qui tout
au départ on tue à s'imposer dans leur
club face au barça quand on est petit
pas moi j'ai commencé avec les garçons
donc c'est un peu compliqué quand les
garçons sont jeunes de voir une fille
qui joue avec eux dans leur équipe ce
n'est pas forcément la personnalité on
va le faire le plus de passes etc
au début ça a été compliqué mais là ça a
évolué donc les gars ont changé ça nous
ennuie les mentalités évoluent voilà qui
sont beaucoup plus acceptée dans les
clubs on le ressent on le perçoit
pour mémoire si la première rencontre de
football féminin a eu en 1917 ce n'est
qu'à la fin des années 60 que la
fédération française reconnaît la
discipline
aujourd'hui les filles de pergaud
imagine qu'elle pourrait peut-être un
genre en faire un métier comme beaucoup
de jeunes filles elle rêverait tout dans
un petit coin de leur tête je pense d'un
joueur professionnel après c'est
compliqué forcément de devenir joueuse
professionnelle mais il ya quelques
belles réussites par l'intermédiaire de
la section sportive depuis depuis 20 ans
il ya un certain nombre de joueuses au
moins une vingtaine qui ont souvent
évolué après en division 2 voire en
refusant au niveau amateur le nombre des
licenciés filles ne cesse de croître et
les clubs comme ici le racing besançon
recrutent les féminines depuis peu une
des joueuses officie même comme arbitre
chez les filles et les garçons profit
les
les joueuses et les joueuses ras le
moins que les garçons souvent parce que
elle simule moi aussi les garçons n'ont
pas hésité à percuter quoi que ce soit à
dribbler fais mien c'est plus dans le
collectif
tu sais juste qu'ils décrivent sur trois
week-ends on vient sur les valeurs du
foot c'est à dire que on retrouve le jeu
était les féminines jouent au ballon il
n'y a pas de discussion sur le terrain
tarik typhon pose de colons se replace
c'est des vrais valeurs depuis la
victoire de la france en russie le
nombre de footballeuses a augmenté de
15% en toute logique les filles de
l'équipe nationale devrait encore
booster les chiffres
est ce que vous pensez qu un effet que
je pense que ça peut contribuer à
l'histoire du foot féminin d'une manière
supplémentaire on va dire et puis je
pense que comme souvent après une coupe
du monde peut être qu'en termes des
licenciés ça risque de d'avoir
effectivement une incidence et voilà ça
peut être que profitable pour le foot
féminin à partir de septembre 2019
on aura encore plus de licenciés chez
les filles quel que soit le parcours de
l'équipe de france après une belle fête
quoi quoi organiser sur notre territoire
évolution des mentalités ouverture des
clubs
nos deux reporters n'ont plus aucun
doute à l'issue de la faune dévouement
il faut s'y mettre
c'est l'événement sportif du moment à la
coupe du monde de foot féminin avec
notamment lundi soir un match à suivre
ça se passera à rennes chez nous et on y
croit c'est pour les huitièmes de finale
tout de même un coup les filles
bienvenue manon et camille nous ont
rejoints bonjour maintenant bonjour
camille jeu tutoyer aussi comme un
nouveau camarade qui était là juste
avant vous ok vous avez envie de nous
parler de quoi vous le maquillage
collège le maquillage au collège ça
tombe bien vous êtes au collège même
collège que vos camarades de jeu le
collage e jean lacaille à bini sur auch
c'est ça qui est l'un des plus petits
collèges de bourgogne franche comté vous
savez ça vous mariez vous êtes moins de
100 élèves c'est ça c'est un tout petit
collège un vraiment un sixième à la
troisième
les profits sont sympas ouais je salue
parce qu'ils sont derrière
j'en profite pour
préciser parce que vous le voyez
s'afficher clemi c'est un partenariat
qui permet aux élèves d'apprendre à lire
et à décrypter l'information et l'image
aussi puis à aiguiser l'esprit critique
ceci expliquant cela pourquoi vous êtes
avec nous toutes les deux pour nous en
dire un peu plus ce coup de gueule coups
de coeur les jeunes ont la parole joly
dit et là c'est pour le maquillage le
racontez moi le maquillage vous en
parlait déjà au collège
ben oui entre filles surtout bas à
partir de la cinquième ouais parce que
ben parce qu'on change score change
parti de la 5e forcément commence à
devenir femme oui et là on se dit en
plus si comme vos camarades vous
regardez un peu les réseaux sociaux on
voit quelques images qui sont un tout
petit peu tronquée et évidemment il ya
du maquillage dans l'air est ce que ça
veut dire que c'est important pour vous
le maquillage pas forcément
ouais vous n'êtes pas d'accord tous les
deux on va commencer par camille basse
et surtout pour avoir ma plus confiance
en soi mais on se crée une façade avec
le maquillage du coup bah c'est plus
vraiment nous enfin si mais plus trop
quoi
d'accord on était quand même toit se
passe quand on est un petit peu de
poudre iwuy bon parfait et toi
maintenant tu en penses quoi
la manière dont on se maquille ouais bah
si on en met beaucoup si on met juste un
peu de mascara un peu de poudre d'accord
donc façon voiture volée c'est pas
possible quoi pour vous ça sert à quoi
de se maquiller basses rendent plus
belles paraître plus âgée way à paraître
plus âgée besoins tant des salariés nous
on aime à vous pour fait pas des métiers
ont beau plus sérieusement quels
conseils donneriez à vos camarades qui
vont peut-être vous revoir sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment sur les écrans
connectés va rester un minimum naturel
et s'interrogent aussi pourquoi on va se
marier après assumer les conséquences
d'accord quelles sont-elles les
conséquences bah si on se maquille comme
une star va assumer les conséquences
aussi de vouloir ressembler à quelqu'un
d'autre
les regards tu veux dire ouais ce qui
est certain c'est que
j'ai pas le sentiment que vous ayez tout
de suite envie de vous maquiller je me
trompe ou pas non je me trompe pas bon
en tout cas quoi qu'il en soit faites
attention si vous vous maquillez quels
conseils vous donneriez aux copines là
qui vous écoute pas de faire attention à
la composition des produits qu'on
utilise pour ma part était de se faire
du mal afin de faire du mal à notre peau
ouais et adapter son maquillage à
l'occasion de dans laquelle oui donc il
faut penser à se démaquiller vont garder
une peau saine et fraîche comme new
marina